thank you for golfers time to tee at hi
and let it fly golf courses across the
state have gotten a word that they can
reopen tomorrow golf is a 1 billion
dollar industry in the state that
employs more than 17,000 people as Ron
future Futrell tells us a lot of people
are really happy to see this happening
all right so there is some genuine
excitement about golf courses opening
tomorrow morning in fact the golf
courses we've talked to today say the
phones have been ringing off the hook
oh we can't be more excited I mean the
phones are ringing off the hook we got
the notice basically yesterday that we
can reopen the facility the Golf Course
in the driving range tomorrow morning at
7 a.m. so we're pretty excited a lot of
people have a lot of pent-up energy they
want to get out in the Sun and they want
to have some good family fun golf
courses are already jumping into action
phones are ringing and online tee times
are being made so everybody's excited
and I think it kind of came of a bit of
a surprise that people thought maybe
mid-may the courses would open so the
governor allowing them to open May first
is huge there's one person per golf cart
now used to be able to have two people
now with the social distancing it's only
allowed to have one person per card so
no doubt about it people are excited to
get out on the golf courses take a swing
whack that ball know you thought I was
gonna hit it didn't you not gonna do
that till tomorrow morning
Ron few are reporting eight news now
this practice swings
today the